alright we're on problem 26 for the
quadrilateral shown below right
quadrilateral has four sides measure of
angle a pushed measure of angle C is
equal to what and here you just should
know that all the sum of all the angles
in a quadrilateral are equal to 360
degrees
and you might say okay that I'll add
that to my my memory bank of things to
memorize like the angles in a triangle
or equal to 180 and I'll show you know
you don't have to memorize that because
if you imagine any quadrilateral let me
draw a quadrilateral for you and this is
true of pretty much any polygon this is
true of any polygon so let's say this is
some quadrilateral right you don't have
to memorize that the sum of the angles
are equal to 360 although it might be
useful for cuadrado but I'll show you
how to always prove it for any polygon
you just break it up into triangles then
you only have to memorize one thing if
you break it up into triangles
you know that the sum of all of these so
this angle Plus that angle Plus that
angle has to be equal to 180 right and
this angle Plus that angle Plus that
angle have to be equal to 180 so if you
were to add up so the angles in the
quadrilateral itself are this angle and
this angle and then this angle and this
angle right well this was just the sum
of those two and this was just the sum
of those two so if these three added up
to 180 and these three out up to 180
this Plus this Plus this Plus this will
add up to 360 and you can do that with
an arbitrarily shaped polygon let say a
five-sided plus two a Pentagon so one
two three four five sides
Wow how many angles are there in a
Pentagon we'll just break it up into
triangles how many triangles can you fit
in it see one two right each of these
triangles their angles they add up to
180 so if you wanted to know you know
that that that Plus that that that Plus
that that that that just be 180 times 3
which is what's 540 and that also would
be the angle measures of the polygon
because these three angles add up to
that angle that's that that angles
add up to that one and angles those
angles add up to that one and those
angles add up to that one so now
hopefully you'll never if I gave you a
20 sided polygon you can figure out oh
how many times can I fit triangles into
it and you'll know how many angles there
are in the sum of all of them
but anyway so going back to the
quadrilateral a quadrilateral the sum of
the angles are going to be 360 degrees
so if we say measure of angle a plus
measure of angle C plus these two angles
so that's what 95 plus let me write it
down plus 95 plus 32 it's going to be
equal to 360 so I'll just write a plus C
just quick notation let's see 95 plus 32
is 127 plus 127 is equal to 360 a plus C
is equal to 360 minus 127 and what is
that that is 233 right and that's the
choice
fair enough question 27 if ABCD is a
parallelogram so that's the sides of
parallel what is the length of segment B
BD so they want from here to here and
this is just another interesting thing
I'm not going to prove it right now but
this is a good thing to know especially
if you if you become a mathlete because
it shows up in math competitions every
now and then and then if you have a
parallelogram right the side opposite
sides are parallel then they're
diagonals are actually bisecting each
other which means that they split the
other diagonal into so this diagonal
splits this diagonal into so this is 6
this is also going to be 6 and this
diagonal splits BD into so if this is 5
and this is also 5 so ve is 5
edie is 5 then BD has to be 10 choice a
let me copy and paste 28 in here 28
a right circular cone has radius five
inches and height eight inches
fair enough they've drawn it for us what
is the lateral area of the cone lateral
a good they gave us a definition lateral
area of a cone is equal to PI times R
times L where L is the slant height so
we know what R is right they give us our
R is five so we just have to figure out
what the slant height is this L well
this looks like a Pythagorean theorem
problem right this is a right angle I
know it's all weird bits as three
dimensions but this forms a right
triangle all right we're just kind of
picking one slice of the cone that
includes the pointy part but it's all we
could say here we say five squared let
me do that five squared plus eight
squared plus eight squared is equal to L
squared
all right this is a right angle L is the
hypotenuse so you get 25 plus 64 is
equal to L squared so that's what 80
eighty nine is equal to L squared and so
L is equal to the square root of 89
unless I've made a mistake someplace
square root of 89 oh good I see a square
root of 89 there already so we probably
are on the right track so L is equal to
square root of 89 and they tell us they
give us the formula for the lateral area
of a cone as pi RL so PI R L is equal to
pi times R the radius of the base which
is 5 times the lateral times this slant
height which is the square root of 89
equals 5 pi times the square root of 89
which is I just peeked and saw choice D
whenever you see a number like 89 you're
beginning to get worried but it's good
that was one of the choices problem 29
okay let me copy and paste it
clear this image clear it's early on a
Saturday morning my wife is still
sleeping we're expecting our first child
in a month so I figure the sleep is good
for her gives me more time to record
math videos as well okay I don't know
why I go on those tangent okay figure
ABCD is a kite and it looks like a kite
what is the area of figure ABCD in
square centimeters in squares central
everything they're giving us is in
centimeter so if we just stay in
centimeters we'll won't have a problem
so what's the area of this so we just
figure out the area of each of these
triangles right and what's the area of a
triangle an area of a triangle is equal
to 1/2 base times height so what's the
area of this triangle well actually this
is symmetric right if we know the area
of this triangle we know the area of
this triangle because this is 6 and 8
this is 6 and 8 so the area of this one
is 6 times 8 is 48 48 times 1/2 is 24
right 6 times 8 is 48 48 times 1/2 24
this one's also going to be 24 by the
same argument so when you add them
together you get 48 right those two
combined are going to be 48 now this
triangle 8 times 15 times 1/2 that's
what 4 times 15 which is equal to 60 and
this is going to have the same area by
the same argument 60 we didn't actually
have to multiply by 1/2 but we're gonna
multiply by 2 eventually or add it to
each other again so anyway we have 60
plus 60 plus 24 plus 24 that's what 120
plus 48 is 168 choice C next problem
problem 31
I like these problems now now that we're
out of the hole the part that they were
getting all into congruence ease and
similars and I thought they made a
couple of mistakes on some of those
anyway
if a cylindrical barrel measures 22
inches in diameter how many inches will
it roll in 8 revolutions along a smooth
surface so let's say so we could have
you know this could we could imagine a a
wiill oh we you know it's a tire of some
kind so let me draw a circle so if we
look at this cylindrical barrel from the
side because that's I think all we care
about that's its side they say a
cylindrical barrel measures 22 inches in
diameter so this this distance right
here you see if I go from that's
distance right there is 22 it's 22 and
what they say is this thing is going to
roll eight revolutions on a smooth
surface it's gonna go around eight times
it's gonna roll and move to the right
right so how long will it roll so if you
think about it it's going to cover its
circumference eight times right if we
start off if this point is starting
touching the ground after after it moves
a circumference a distance that point
will be touching the ground again right
and the easy way to think about it is as
this thing moves to the right as it
rolls when it moves one foot one foot
along of circumference will then be
touching the ground when it moves or
once every word when it moves to to
whatever inches or whatever then two
inches long if its enemy of along that
circumference will be touching the
ground right so it's going to go eight
circumference --is in eight revolutions
so what's the circumference of this
circumference is equal to PI times the
diameter the diameter they already gave
us was 22 so the conference is equal to
22 pi so it's going to move eight
circumference --is in eight revolutions
so twenty two pi times eight is what 160
176 pi and that's choice C see in the
next video